la soirée a débuté sur une mise en scène
un contrôle d'identité sans raison
apparente
mourad s'est glissé pour cette fois dans
la peau d'un militaire israélien pour
mieux décrire son quotidien et celui de
chérine deux jeunes habitants d'hébron
en palestine - corps en tant que cameron
it
je suis jamais été dans la rue
principale de ma vie donc c'était
c'était fermé avant que je sois né
l'impossibilité de se déplacer dont la
vieille ville les discriminations subies
ou encore la peur de marcher dans les
rues le soir ces deux jeunes
palestiniens ont témoigné directement
sans intermédiaire l'objectif affiché
par la conférence ça permet à chacun de
se faire sa propre idée au delà de ce
que on peut penser de ce qu'on peut
entendre sur la situation et le conflit
au moyen-orient et donc chacun peut voir
directement poser ces questions on
voulait simplement avoir un témoignage
sans avoir une influence derrière
d'intérêt l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines était la
première étape d'une série de
conférences organisées partout en france
jusqu'au 1er mars
des conférences pour en savoir un peu
plus sur la vie des plus jeunes
piégé dans l'un des conflits les plus
vieux du monde